well the the large issues I think are
how are we as a as a people as
individuals States country going to deal
with the challenges of globalization
over the pair of the future are we going
to be driven out by these forces or are
we going to be willing to grasp them and
to shape them and turn them into our
advantage I think that's a central
challenge and that means investing in
people investing in education skills
other kinds of issues or questions and I
think a follow-up answer to that is to
understand the strengths of the nation
which is our values that's what we are
when we are respected as a country
that's what we're respected for though
those are the values which are inscribed
both in the Declaration of Independence
and also in in the in the Constitution
those are the values that were expressed
yeah in the in the in the ship mate the
Mayflower with the Mayflower Compact
about our sense of community and the
value of being together it's described
in the Constitution the general welfare
of our nation that's when we have been
our best and I think those are that's
our greatest strengths the greatest
challenge i think is whether we're going
to be how we're going to cope with the
central challenges of a rapidly changing
world and i think the other great
challenge is how we're going to maintain
this strength of sense of community and
value which has been such a compelling
force in the shaping our own lives and
also in shaping the lives
you